The Joe Rogan Experience Garrett
vandenbush said this is going to become
a pandemic of variance and he talked
about immune escape and
that has been very controversial but did
you explain that to people
sure what he argued and let's just say
could you explain who he is too sure he
is a uh immunobiologist he is training
his Veterinary he has training in the
relevant area of vaccination technology
he was a guest on Dark Horse people can
look up my discussion with him it is
many people regard it as a very good way
to understand what he's saying because
often he speaks about matters that are
quite technical in any way I did my best
in that podcast to to make it
non-technical so that people could
understand it
in any case what he argued was that the
fact of these vaccines being very
narrowly targeted right these vaccines
contain a single subunit of a single
protein
and they're being deployed in a way that
is unusual they're being deployed into
an active pandemic right when we
immunize against something like measles
the expectation is you will develop your
full immunity with almost no chance of
encountering measles right in this case
what we have are vaccines that are leaky
in which they do not provide full
sterilizing immunity
they are narrow and we are effectively
creating an intense evolutionary
pressure to cause the spike protein of
which this one subunit is what is
contained with the information for it is
contained in the vaccines we are putting
intense evolutionary pressure on it to
change so that the antibodies and other
immune cell recognition mechanisms that
are trained by the vaccines are
incapable of finding the pathogen when
it gets in this is what causes
breakthrough cases that the immunity
that's been created is evaded by the
pathogen and if the pathogen changes
that is more likely and so what he said
was
if you vaccinate into an active pandemic
with vaccines like this what you will
get is a evolutionary pressure for a
radiation of variants an evolutionary
radiation of different molecular
signatures changes in the spike protein
that will then cause the vaccines to be
less and less effective at producing
immunity which is exactly what we see so
he predicted this absolutely he did
predict accurately accurate accurately
predicted it now is every component of
his model correct that's a much harder
question to answer but what I would say
is any time somebody succeeds in
predicting better than the so-called
experts
you want to know how they did it and
he was making absolute evolutionary
sense right his concerns were very well
honed and he was making sense and then
the world that he predicted emerged and
it is now incumbent on us to say okay
have we learned anything from this right
do the vaccines need to be modified such
that they don't produce this effect
there are conceivable ways you could do
that right but if we don't do it if we
just say well more of the same have a
booster of the same thing it's not going
to solve the problem so in effect what I
would say is these vaccines are a
spectacular achievement but they are a
prototype right they have achieved
something that had never been done
before technologically that's remarkable
but they were not ready for prime time
and they have failed to produce lasting
immunity they have produced very narrow
immunity it does not compare to the
natural immunity that people get from
having had and beaten the disease and
what's more
we have learned an awful lot about how
the disease can be managed so it's much
less lethal right that combination
suggests that we need a rethinking of
our approach
and you know it is impossible to prove
but based on what people who have
successfully treated the disease and
have successfully predicted events like
the proliferation of variants are
telling us it does seem that we now have
the tools at our disposal to manage this
crisis and do away with it which
I don't know why we don't do that but it
is at least worth noting
that were we to successfully manage it
it would interrupt a huge flow of
Revenue into this brand new Pharma
Market is that the reason that we don't
do it I don't know but
we the public need to recognize our
interests
are not being served by the public
health apparatus it is making errors
that it doesn't need to make and that
that
um
has implications for all of our
individual health and our Collective
well-being that require a rethink watch
the entire episode for free only on
Spotify